einerseits hat mich maßlos geärgert was
jetzt rausgekommen ist
andererseits freut es mich
dass diese
wandlitzblase von öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk Radio Berlin-Brandenburg
vielleicht kommen andere noch nach
endlich geplatzt ist endlich geplatzt
ist wir haben das teuerste
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk und
fernsehwesen auf der Welt
mit 8,4 Milliarden jährlich
zwangsfinanziert paar 100 Millionen
Werbeeinnahmen kommen noch mit dazu und
dass da endlich reingeleuchtet wurde und
ich hoffe dass die Staatsanwaltschaften
das noch tun und wer ist nicht bezahlt
die 18 Euro der muss ja Knast das
absitzen auch diese Fälle hatten wir
nein ich möchte dass der Weg beschlossen
wird wie ihn jetzt teilweise die
Franzosen eingeschlagen haben sie wollen
die Rundfunkgebühren abschaffen ja ich
möchte sie abschaffen